hey guys Pete here I'm getting ready to
put out some videos related to brands
role in the end of the series so today I
wanted to talk about the three-eyed
Raven this will contain spoilers if you
aren't caught up to the end of season 6
in the show and will reveal a lot from
the books so if you are reading them or
planning to read them and don't want
this character spoiled this is your
warning also I have a book giveaway
going on so make sure you watch to the
end to find out more about that in the
show Game of Thrones brand sets out with
Meera and Jojen Reed to find a
three-eyed Raven that has been visiting
him in his dream in the books it is
called the three-eyed crow and I guess
the show just wanted to be certain that
since the Nights Watch are called crows
that there wouldn't be a mix-up more or
less whether you think of it as a
three-eyed Raven or a three-eyed crow
the character plays the same part big
difference in the show is that the
three-eyed Raven mentions being in the
tree for a thousand years my guess is
that they did this to simplify the
character since he could serve his
purpose without the backstory but in the
books we know who he actually is we also
know a lot about his history which may
help understand where the story is going
so fundamentally the character serves
the same purpose but the person isn't
necessarily the same with that said I
think it is both interesting and
important to look at what we know about
the three-eyed crow we find out in the
fifth book at Dance with Dragons that
the three-eyed crow is a Targaryen
bastard named Brendan rivers so first
I'm going to go over what we know about
his history and how he ended up in the
cave and then we'll get into his
relationship branch Brendan rivers is an
albino with milk white skin long white
hair and red eyes he has a red birthmark
on the right side of his face that
stretches from his cheek down to his
throat this is where his nickname blood
Raven comes from since the birthmark is
said to look like a raven drawn in blood
Brendan was an expert Bowman he lost one
of his eyes during the first Blackfyre
rebellion and rarely wore a patch to
cover it up he chose to display his scar
and empty socket to the world he had
long white hair to his shoulders that he
sort of brushed forward to cover up his
missing eye he was born in King's
Landing as a bastard son of King Aegon
the fourth Targaryen a Gaul most was
fond of keeping mistresses and Brendan's
mother Lady Melissa Blackwood was his
six he has two sisters Maya and gwennyth
rivers and even though the
eventually moved on to his seventh
mistress brington was able to keep close
relations at court because of his
mother's popularity a strong warrior
Brendan carried the Valyrian steel blade
dark sister but preferred to use his
weirwood longbow and was an expert
Archer Brennan served on the small
Council of his half-brother Darrin the
second Targaryen during the first
Blackfyre rebellion
Brendan remain loyal to King Daeron and
commanded a group of longbowman called
the ravens teeth at the Battle of red
grassfield he lost an eye finding his
half-brother bittersteel the Ravens
teeth ultimately gained the weeping
Ridge and rained down arrows on to
daemon Blackfyre from 300 yards away
killing Damon and his twin sons for this
act people would name Brendan a
Kingslayer after the war he advocated a
hard line against the rebels winning out
over Prince BAE Lars called for leniency
rivers became handed the King serving
throughout the reign of his nephew King
Aerys the first Targaryen this isn't the
Mad King Aerys he was Aerys the second
it was a tough time for the crown as the
great spring sickness killed tens of
thousands and was followed by a drought
that lasted like over a year with so
much going wrong the small folk started
to blame Bloodraven since they
considered him a kin slayer and they
weren't big fans of his interest in
sorcery
bloodraven played important roles in the
second and third Blackfyre rebellion but
his involvement in the Great Council of
233 is what sealed his fate
Brendan continued his hand for Harris's
successor his brother make art the first
in 221 after my car's death in 223
Brendan has handed the King called a
Great Council on King's Landing to
discuss the disputed matter of
succession a nice black fire wanted to
peacefully participate in the Great
Council and bloodraven offered him safe
conduct to King's Landing from Tyra
once a niece arrived in the capital
however he was arrested by the gold
cloaks and then beheaded in the red keep
the great council chose make our son to
succeed as King Aegon v Targaryen whose
first act was to arrest Bloodraven for
the murder of a nice it is suggested by
maester aemon that Brendan was
imprisoned in the red keeps dungeon
Brendan argued that he had sacrificed
his honor for the good of the realm but
Aegon refused to set Brendan free he did
offer the option of taking the black
instead of death which Brendan happily
accepted when maester aemon
for the wall in 2:33 he was escorted by
King Aegon v friend sir Duncan the tall
of the Kingsguard and accompanied by an
honor guard of recruits for the Nights
Watch these were two hundred men and
prisoners among them Brynden rivers and
archers from his Ravens t brendan rose
to the position of Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch in 239 however he
disappeared while ranging beyond the
wall in 252 this is all that we know
about bloodraven from his life before
the cave keep in mind that events in the
show and in Song of Ice and Fire books
take place starting in 298 which is
about 46 years after he disappeared from
his ranging beyond the wall from there
no one knows what happened to him until
Bryan arrives at the cave bran story is
influenced by the three-eyed raven early
on though and if you subscribe to the
theory about the dire wolves it's
possible that brendan was pulling
strings right from the very start when
Brandon is coma after being pushed from
the tower a crow appears in his dreams
to tell bran it can teach him to fly it
has three eyes and guides him out of
this coma and another dream the
three-eyed crow goes with Brant when he
speaks to Ned in the crypts of
Winterfell this was actually before Ned
was dead as well like before his
beheading later bran meets Jojen and
Meera read at Winterfell after having a
dream of a weirwood with deep red eyes a
twisted wooden mouth and a three-eyed
raven in its branches
Jojen tells bran that he dreamed of a
winged wolf bound in chains and that he
saw a three-eyed raven chipping away at
those chains
Jojen also reveals that the crow has
been visiting him and dreams since he
was a kid and it can be found like north
beyond the wall they decide to travel
north to find the bird and eventually
find the location in a cave in the
haunted forest of course it's not an
actual bird but a man who we can figure
out his Brynden rivers or Lord
bloodraven if you prefer at this point
he is basically part of the trees root
system but his birthmark and the fact
that he only has one red eye it makes
him pretty easy to identify weirwood
roots surround the man and grow through
his body including his leg and his empty
eye socket his voice is slow and dry as
if he had forgotten how to speak bran is
disappointed that the crow cannot heal
his crippled legs but Brendon promises
he will teach bran how to fly instead
Brenda teaches bran about green singing
and skin changing he later decides
time for bran to take the next step and
has Leif give brand a bowl of weirwood
paste which is made from the seeds of
weirwood to eat in order to awaken his
greenseer gifts there is a theory about
it being Jojen in the bowl but we're
gonna I'm just gonna skip over that idea
when Bryan sees his father Eddard
through winter fells heart tree Brendan
tells bran that he is haunted by his own
ghost he talks of a brother he that he
loved a brother that he hated and a
woman he that he desired but he tells
bran from his experience that he knows
you can't change the past
that's where it's at in the books and
obviously the show went a little past
this point and Game of Thrones we saw
the end of the three-eyed Raven when the
White Walkers entered the cave and we
have heard bran say that now he is the
three-eyed Raven what that means exactly
isn't clear it means that we can expect
to learn more about events through the
weirwood trees but what else did the
three-eyed Raven actually do well we
know he guided bran and Jojen through
dreams to make this difficult journey
north of the wall there are also plenty
of other possible examples where he
might have intervened in events by skin
changing into ravens another animal it's
also possible that he might have had a
hand an egg on the unlikeliest rise to
the throne despite being a fourth born
son which would be kind of ironic since
Aegon had Bloodraven arrested in his
first act as the king well bran be able
to start doing these types of things
well you know will he'd be able to enter
people's thoughts with dreams will it be
able to push people in different
directions or is his main purpose in the
show now to just to reveal John's
parentage it's really hard to say but I
kind of doubt that the only thing bran
is going to do that this newfound power
is travel to winter phone then just
chill I plan on making more videos based
on branch dreams and how what we know
from those might tell us of what his
role in season seven and eight will be
so let me know what you guys think and
let me know what other videos about bran
or bloodraven you want to see bloodraven
is one of my favorite characters from
the book so it's exciting to think about
what bran might be able to do I'm not
even gonna get into the whole weirwood
net idea or how the children are
involved in this this particular video
but I will just mention that one thing I
would love to see as brand getting a
look at the Isle of faces let me know
what you're hoping bran will show us and
how you think we might see him use his
powers please give the video a like if
you thought it was
singing be sure to subscribe to my
channel for a chance to win in the
giveaway when I reach 18,000 subscribers
I'm giving away a copy of a night of the
Seven Kingdoms by george RR martin all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so subscribe now and leave a
comment for your chance to win thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon